hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast what's new in robotics and
minimally invasive therapy for prostate
cancer and prostate disease I'm Brenda
Kelly chem lab roots ma be your
moderator for today's event labret
believing scientific social networking
site we are proud to bring you this
interactive web seminar for more
information please visit us at wwe.com
here's how the presentation works we
want to hear from me questions comments
for answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen if time permits we'll get
your questions at the end of the
presentation if you can hear see this
presentation properly let us know and
clicking on the support button top right
or the Q&A button in the lower left in
addition we want to let our audience
note this presentation has been approved
for continuing education credits if you
want to obtain the credits please click
and you get your free CME CP button
located in the lower left of your screen
this will take you to a page listing all
of our speakers and presentations you
select the CEC any button under your
presentation and follow the instructions
to claim your certificate I would now
like to introduce today's speakers dr.
Herbert lepore MD is one of the leading
experts in the field of prostate cancer
who's currently the Martin SPECT
chairman of the department of neurology
and the director of the smile of
comprehensive prostate care center at
the nyu langone medical center in new
york dr. david m albela is chief of
urology krause hospital in syracuse new
york and the medical director for
associated medical professionals we
considered a national and international
authority and laparoscopic and robotic
surgery and has been an active teacher
in this year over 20 years his research
and clinical interests have focused on
robotic neurological surgery in addition
dr. Obama is a past boy House Fellow
react was a special assistant to
federico pena secretary of
transportation and classic
and unclassified public health related
issues to learn more about either of our
speakers please click on their names
I'll now turn it over to dr. before to
start us off it's a pleasure to
participate in this debate open versus
robotic-assisted laparoscopic radical
prostatectomy so in the year 2015 about
80% of radical prostatectomies in the US
will be performed via robotic approach
so was the adoption of the robot driven
by evidence-based improvements of
oncological functional outcomes or
significant cost reduction or
disingenuous marketing by industry
hospitals and surgeons well who cares
some may say let's move on since
everyone's doing the robot and trainees
no longer exposed to the open approach
we all need to care new technology is
often costly and adoption associated
with the learning curve we need to
protect the consumer and the payers of
health care there must be a legitimate
process for evaluation and adoption of
new technology so why didn't I jump on
the robot bandwagon well in the early
2000s the major limitation of open
radical prostatectomy was post
prostatectomy sexual dysfunction at that
time my length of stay following radical
prostatectomy was less than two days
hospital mortality and over 3,000 cases
at that time 0 less than 1%
intra-operative perioperative
complications transfusion rates of 4%
half the men were back to work in two
weeks ninety-seven percent urinary
continence and so I speculated that
magnification and thermal the section of
the neurovascular bundle simply would
not improve sexual function so I believe
radical prostatectomy filled that unmet
niche for the surgical robot rather than
the robot addressing a legitimate
limitation of open radical prostatectomy
I predicted that the robot would not
improve outcomes and that's what I'll
show you today in this debate I did not
anticipate that savvy marketing would
drive patient care and not medical
evidence so this is some of the
marketing I believe this is at the
stadium with the Red Sox
robotic-assisted surgery made me famous
bringing it to Brighton makes me proud
this is what I deal with up the street
here in new york city from dr. Samadi
website that's splitting the muscle and
putting it on traction for three to four
hours causes a lot of pain that's a
longer recovery if you were just using
your hands and you're working in blind
spots you can damage the sphincter that
leads to incontinence you can leave
cancer behind under the pubic bone
because those are the blind spots is
this disingenuous marketing or is this
evidence-based medicine let's see so if
we wanted to do a comparative
effectiveness of open versus robotic
radical prostatectomy we need to
consider these outcomes at this business
priority oncologic control operative in
perioperative complications quality of
life outcomes and cost and then there is
really those outcomes of really less
importance blood loss cosmetics length
of stay and whether you use a suprapubic
tube versus a Foley catheter now there
are many factors that influence a
comparative effectiveness of open versus
robotic radical prostatectomy for
example disease characteristics if
you're comparing two groups open versus
robot were they similar Gleason score
clinical stage and serum PSA how about
patient characteristics with a baseline
urinary and sexual function equivalent
age and comorbidities very important
i'll show you this with some very
compelling evidence surgeon experience
and technical abilities is at work with
the hospitals with a metric balanced by
metropolitan versus rural tertiary
Center versus community hospital or
clinical pathways
and the outcome assessment was it
prospective or retrospective where their
instruments for assessing outcomes and
was their attempt to reduce investigator
bias well the feasibility of a
randomized comparative effectiveness
study is it is it's just simply not
practical and however it really would
give us the ultimate answer that would
give us the so based on all the
confounders of comparative effectiveness
a randomized study is necessary to
definitively compare open versus robotic
radical prostatectomy however a
randomized study would be
cost-prohibitive and not feasible since
surgeons and patients are not willing to
submit to randomization so the
methodology for comparing open versus
robotic radical probably do this in the
absence of a randomized study well if
we're going to look at the comparative
effectiveness again we must consider the
surgeons of equivalent experience there
must be uniform clinical pathways for
pain management transfusion hospital
discharge and readmission really needs
to be central pathology validated
outcome instruments must be used the
surgeon should be uninvolved in data
accrual entry or retrieval and efforts
must be made to adjust for author bias
so in this debate I will not show you a
single comparison of single surgeon
experiences from different institutions
i will show you no meta analysis because
it's basically garbage in garbage out no
single surgeon comparing their personal
open and robotic outcomes it just shows
if that surgeon is a better open or
robotic surgeon I will rely on single
institution with high volume surgeons
and uniform clinical pathways in
pathology assessment and large
administrative databases still
recognizing that there are inherent
limitations of this literature this is
one of the most important slides and
what it shows is robot
versus open radical prostatectomy the
differential effect of regionalization
procedure volume and operative approach
and this comes from the nationwide
sample know if you notice with the open
in the dotted blue and the robotic and
the dotted red so on the x-axis is
annual Hospital case volume so when you
look at hospitals that perform less than
50 cases there are significant
complications in both the open and
robotic groups so you sometimes hear
that then well you know maybe the robot
doesn't make a good surgeon better it
makes a bad surgeon a better bad surgeon
well I would say back surgeons shouldn't
be doing this and what you can see is a
low volume robotic surgeon has the same
complications that a low volume open
surgery would have and similarly in
experience opening robotic surgeons can
perform this operation safely and we'll
come back to this so let's look at
positive surgical margins I believe this
is really one of the very best studies
in the literature it comes from Brigham
and Women's Hospital the open and
robotic cases were performed by highly
experienced surgeons in fact that there
was twice the number of robotic cases as
open cases there was a single group of
pathologists and the positive surgical
margin rate was fourteen percent versus
eight percent the rat the robot versus
the open and when they made all of the
adjustments the conclusion was that men
undergoing a robotic assisted
laparoscopic radical prostatectomy for
about two times more likely to have a
positive surgical margin compared to the
open approach when both procedures were
performed by experts positive surgical
margin again was adjusted for
preoperative disease will now here's
another study from memorial
sloan-kettering we're again this was
2007 and then in two thousand at 10 and
this was fourteen hundred and fifty four
men and all of the surgeons were high
volume surgeon
both open and robotic and in this case
the surgical approach had no impact on
positive surgical margins or recurrent
now let's go to Hopkins between the
years 2005 and 2011 again we're looking
at a group of highly experienced open
and robotic surgeons and if you look at
the number of procedures again it shows
that these were on average high volume
surgeons the mean length of stay at
Hopkins if you had the road open was
significantly less than if you had the
robot the off pathway discharged
typically because of again some some
factor causing delay was significantly
greater in the robotic crew and if you
look at the radical prostatectomy
specific complications they were
significantly higher in the robot versus
the open cohort so the robotic approach
independent predictor of increased off
pathway discharge and radical
prostatectomy specific complications
well that's let's go now to to
Vanderbilt again highly experienced the
open and robotic surgeons and what did
we learn from this institutions
experience again they had similar
pathways and outcome instruments for men
undergoing open and robotic radical
prostatectomy and over the years they
reported no significant differences
between the surgical approaches for
length of stay for pain for transfusion
rates for continent rates for potency
rates for surgical margins when you
corrected for pathologic stage or
biochemical recurrence there was again
and the only differentiation between the
groups was greater blood loss associated
with the open approach well let's look
at satisfaction and we're learn to do
and I imagine some of these cases may
have been contributed by dr. o Baba a
good friend and colleague who is at
debating the merits of the robotics so
it Duke and this was between the years
thousand seven men undergoing the
robotic radical prostatectomy were three
times more likely to regret undergoing
their radical prostatectomy and in
subsequent publications the greater
satisfaction rate was felt to be
attributed to unrealistic expectations
well let's look at the health care
professions follow-up study to see if we
can glean some again a reasonably
reliable a comparative effectiveness
observations no significant difference
in positive surgical margins and
recurrences biochemical recurrences at
three and five years and no see
different significant difference in
health-related quality of life outcomes
now I think this is really the best
study in the literature comparing open
versus robotic functional outcomes again
this was reported by Mike Barry who is
was a p.i and he's the chief of medicine
at Mass General Hospital who's an expert
in health policy he does not care if the
if his study shows an advantage to the
open versus the robot he's just trying
to get to the answer using the the
optimal methodology so questionnaires
were sent to Medicare participants
undergoing radical prostatectomy between
august 2008 and december of 2008 and
this is very important because this was
in the post adoption era for the robot
and since prostate cancer surgery the
question asked how much of a problem
have you had leaking or dripping urine
or was sexual activity and if you look
at the open versus the robotic groups it
was actually when adjustments were made
there was a significantly greater
likelihood that nin who had the robot
had more likely a probability of having
a problem with their confidence and
there was no clinically or a
statistically significant difference in
terms of sexual function
I'm looking at again the the
complications and this was from gundalia
in 2014 looking at the seer Medicare
database again between october two
thousand eight and december two thousand
nine this is the post adoption era for
the robot looking at the robotic radical
prostatectomy had significantly greater
30 and 90 day GU complications and
miscellaneous complications the robot
had a lower risk of blood transfusion
and a length of stay there was no
differences in post prostatectomy cancer
treatments and the robotic approach as
one would expect was significantly more
costly in terms of looking at cost and
we turn to the University of Pittsburgh
where there was you know uniform
pathways leading to hospital discharge
men undergoing open radical
prostatectomy admitted to a specialized
inpatient nursing unit and it looked at
indirect costs and included purchase and
maintenance of the robot and again if
you looked at length of stay there was
no significant differences between the
two groups the robotic approach was a
was took longer to perform and as you
can see a very significant difference in
in cost so let me sort of comment on I
think some studies that had been used
this should show the advantages of the
the robot over the open and let me sort
of point out some of the limitations of
these studies so this is part of
positive surgical margin and
perioperative complication rates of
primary surgical treatments for prostate
cancer a systematic review and
meta-analysis now this was the first
hospital with a shed tiwari but let's
see who was one of the authors let's
look at d this was Lucius ash hardy
accreted and his affiliation is the
department of clinical affairs at
intuitive surgical
so do you think of that there is a
potential author bias when the head of
clinical affairs from the robot is one
of the primary authors I would have I
would be very suspect so what did they
do they took 400 original articles that
were published between two thousand and
two thousand and now that's deceptive
because these articles were published
during that era that I'll show you
there's a real difference in when these
cases were performed the radical
prostatectomies were actually performed
between 1990 and 2000 and we know that
robotic radical prostatectomies were not
performed until after the year 2000 so
there was no correction for the year of
surgery and what happened during this
interval of time was something very
significant and that was PSA testing
which greatly changed the detection a
profile of the cancers of prostate
cancers so again here is the assistant
systematic review and we're going from
1982 to 2010 and let's look at when the
open radical prostatectomies working or
perform the majority of these cases were
actually performed in the pre PSA era
now let's look at the radical robotic
prostatectomy series and of course all
of these were performed after the year
2000 which again is in the in the post
of PSA era so again you can see that
this is apples and oranges this is
basically comparing surgical margins
from the pre PSA to the post PSA error
this is just a hopelessly flawed now
these are highlights from my
publications and when i published the
the complication rates from a surgical
series
of mine from 1994 to 2000 the positive
surgical margin rate was twenty percent
look what happened in another study we
published from the year 2002-2006 my
positive surgical margin rate was nine
point eight percent what accounted for
this dramatic reduction in positive
surgical margin rate is not my learning
curve because I've already done
thousands by the time this in in 1994
but rather it was the routine use of PSA
screening and again if you go back to
the data from the tiwari paper those who
underwent open had higher PSAs and they
had a greater likelihood of having a PT
3 disease and so what you see are our
differences in in in positive surgical
margin rates that again are simply due
to different cancers that were being
diagnosed in this in this era another
study a multi-institutional a
multinational multi-institutional study
comparing positive surgical margin rates
among 22,000 open laparoscopic and
robotic assisted cases now again in this
study they actually were looking at men
who had their surgery from a similar era
ok and again at first blush you would
interpret a significant reduction in
positive surgical margins but the
attributed to the robot but again the
devil is in the details so this is
actually a slide you can't read but I'm
going to highlight some of the important
facts and again this is looking at the
open versus the the robotic experience
now again this is showing you the
center's right so you had one open
Center contributed seventy percent of
the cases
and also look at this seventy-seven
percent of the open cases had missing
data non randomized missing data no
pathological standards confounders
center versus surgeon at what point do
methodological imitation just make a
study uninterpretable and again this is
looking at the open versus the the the
robotic cases again recognizing that
virtually all of the cases the
overwhelming majority of the 14 centers
that you had basically a one major open
center and in fact this is really
comparing one center versus 14 and again
many of the open cases performed at
these centers were being done by a low
volume surgeons so the unadjusted
positive margin rate there was an
advantage to the robot and after the
adjustment and they claim there still
was some differences but the take-home
message for me is that at a high volume
robotic center which was basically all
but one Center you should not have an
open there now let's talk a minute about
some of the functional outcomes so be
very careful when you look at the
systematic reviews so again this was
reported by takara and what they
reported was 51 articles published
between january 2008 and August 2011
eighty-four percent of these had level
three or four evidence that's why i say
garbage in garbage out there was no
uniform methodology for reporting and
confidence no quality control for
reporting outcomes and they assess the
confidence at at one at one year so let
me just give you an example of one of
those studies that contributed that too
med analysis by Tiwari they looked at
three hundred men who under one radical
prostatectomy at Henry Ford Hospital
between October 1999 in december 2002
there was a hundred open versus 200
robotic cases we actually go through
this because there were seven open
surgeons and one team performed all the
robotic cases basically there were five
cases per open surgeon per year vs 70
cases per robotic surgeon per year so
again you have an expert robotic surgeon
and basically inexperienced that open
surgeons are certainly extremely low
volume open surgeons that's not a fair
comparison and of the 300 cases only a
hundred and twenty or forty percent
participated in a phone interview and
sixty percent were simply lost to
follow-up now this is a study that was
recently published and again let me do
thi like some of the pitfalls because at
first blush it really looks like we're
finally going to get the answer this is
by Haglund at all they reported a
prospective study a controlled
non-randomized comparative study of 7
Oakland vs 7 robotic centers in Sweden
quest quality of life questionnaire
completed at baseline and one year and
it was sent to a data monitoring center
this is great it takes out investigator
biased there was uniform definition of
confidence and potency again an
important strength of the study and
again of the 26 25 cases 93% completed
the one year evaluation so really very
few were lost to follow-up so there was
no significant difference between the
baseline PSA gleason score iief ipss
amongst the two groups so these were
really you know a well-balanced for what
one might think would be confounders of
outcome now men undergoing open radical
prostatectomy however were significantly
more likely to live in the rural
area be less educated have higher
baseline BMI and a higher SI
classification now this is very
important overall there were 778 open
cases and eighteen hundred and
forty-seven robotic cases over a three
year interval so what does that really
translate to at the open hospitals they
were performing 37 / radicals per year
vs 88 at the robot now remember that
slide I showed you earlier on showing
you that really it is the experience at
the or the hospital volume that is a
very important predictor of outcomes
look we're 30 cases per year would put
you on this complication limb it's
pretty pretty it that this is a
hospitals that you would expect my
complications and look where the 90
cases of the Rope you're already seeing
the curves flattened out so this was
really comparing low volume open to
intermediate volume robotic centers and
again if you looked at the outcomes
changed the pad at least once a day it
was twenty percent in the open versus
twenty one percent in the robot and
actually if you look at that because the
confidence intervals don't overlap there
would be an advantage to the to be open
now let's look at the iief this is very
important so what this is basically say
or if you looked at penile stiffness in
less than fifty percent of the cases
let's look at that so that was that
eighty-one percent in the open really
would have significant erectile
dysfunction where they had an unreliable
erection versus seventy-seven percent in
the robot so again this became
marginally statistically significant
because of the large sample size but
would you consider an 81
percent versus seventy-seven percent
risk of Ed to be a significant
difference I wouldn't but that was
statistically significant and that led
to the conclusion of robot superiority
over the open and if you looked at the
oncological outcomes there was no
difference so is a superior results of
robotic approach real is a potency rate
of nineteen percent versus twenty-three
percent clinically significant I don't
think so now this is also something of
great concern if again I said it was
equivalent baseline Gleason score in PSA
why did thirty two percent of the men
undergoing and open not undergo a nerve
sparing procedure versus only sixteen
percent of those undergoing the robotic
approach so this is really almost a
comparison of the merits of nerve
sparing now do we think that rural men
with less education were offered
equivalent penile rehabilitation and EB
treatment by open surgeons who are less
likely to perform nerve-sparing
procedures compared to robotic surgeons
Oh think so so what can we conclude from
the recent Swedish study that it's
basically comparison of low volume open
versus intermediate wrong robotic
centers with no correction for hospital
volume low volume open centers and
intermediate volume robotic centers
achieve comparable confidence and
oncologic and oncologic outcomes potency
rates at one year are poor for both open
and robotic centers and the difference
we see between these two groups may be
statistically but it's certainly not
clinically significant and the
negligible difference in potency rate
due to surgeon experience selection bias
inconsistent pathway for treating post
prostatectomy ed and the low rate of
nerve sparing in the open group so
robotic radical prostatectomy has less
blood loss I would say so what oncologic
and functional outcomes are equivalent
or inferior with the robotic approach
we've shown that the amount of blood
loss does not influence oncologic or
function
outcomes so less blood loss does not
translate to improved outcomes and again
that's what the the literature shows the
Vanderbilt experience has shown that
their robotic approach is associated
with one unit less blood loss over the
open which may influence recovery but
I've also shown if you use erythrocytes
stimulating proteins you'll actually
increase the blood volume by one unit so
the only advantage of the robotic
approach is really less blood loss so a
comparative effectiveness which is
really what this debate is all about in
2015 what can we say the only inherit
advantage of robotic radical
prostatectomy is less blood loss that's
it the only inherent advantage of open
radical prostatectomy is less cost I
have to say when you really look at the
highest level of the comparative
effectiveness literature the
preponderance of evidence shows no
inherent advantage of the robotic as it
relates to length estate complications
oncologic outcomes or quality of life
outcomes in fact high quality evidence
suggests an inferiority the robot is
simply a bad investment for improving
outcomes I would have to say that the
most cost effective strategy for
improving outcomes is for radical
prostatectomies to be performed at
centers performing high volumes of open
radical prostatectomy so that really is
the case for the for the open radical
prostatectomy there there there
certainly is a learning curve with new
technology as we saw with a robot but
you justified that learning curve by
ultimately reducing complications or
lowering costs the robot does not lower
complication does not lower oncological
comes does not improve functional
outcomes it's simply more costly and
there's really nothing to justify the
significant
adoption learning curve in and in 2015 I
think we have to say the robot really
did not advance the field of treating
localized prostate cancer good afternoon
welcome to our debate on robotic
prostatectomy vs. open prostatectomy I'm
Dave albela chief of urology at Cross
Hospital and it's indeed a pleasure to
be with you this afternoon I would like
to share the robotic prostatectomy
perspective and the real question to us
is this a surgical advantage or a
marketing ploy you've heard from my
debater dr. laporte my good friend at
NYU and now I will show you the robotic
material and let you make the final
decision on what you think is best for
your patience open prostatectomy or
robotic prostatectomy if we look back
and think about what our goals were for
robotic prostatectomy back in two
thousand we wanted to establish a
minimally invasive option and attempt to
make laparoscopic prostatectomy a more
feasible option for a larger number of
surgeons this procedure as many of you
know it's extremely difficult to perform
and was limited to some very skilled
laparoscopic surgeons initially when we
started with robotics and laparoscopic
procedures the instrumentation was
primitive and the approach was primitive
but I think over the years we've
achieved goals and expectations well
beyond our initial expectations the
approach and expectations of robotic
prostatectomy have evolved significantly
since the year 2000 and continued to
evolve if we look at where the robotic
installations have been across the
United States as well as across the
world
you can see almost 2,000 robots are in
the United States with 220 and Asia and
430 in Europe Australia the Middle East
and Latin America are far behind with 25
robots apiece but when we look at least
in the United States when we compare
open prostatectomy with robotic
prostatectomy practice patterns have
begun to change you can see in the red
is the robot is the radical open
retropubic prostatectomy is popularized
by Patrick Walsh and what my esteemed
colleague dr. lepore has talked about in
2010 you can see that these numbers have
dwindled in the green line you can see
are the robotic prostatectomy and indeed
in 2004 there were very few perform and
then today as you can see that number
has surpassed open prostatectomy across
the board is robotic surgery only
market-driven as my colleague has tried
to parlay and show to us indeed we've
seen articles in the Los Angeles Times
the New York Times as well as the
Seattle Times talking about robotic
surgery its growth but many questions
exist and indeed i think patient
expectations are incredibly important to
have patients realize what the robot can
do as robotic surgeons managing these
expectations beyond the hype is a
challenge and indeed reporting these
outcomes has been difficult and trying
to get patients to understand the
technicalities that are involved with
robotic surgery can pose to be a
challenge in fact as dr. lepore
mentioned this was an article that I
wrote with my colleagues at Duke
University in which patients that
underwent robotic prostatectomy were
more likely to be regretful and
dissatisfied possibly because of the
high expectations of a new procedure
when I first started doing this
procedure expectations were high
patients came in wanting to have this
procedure done and indeed expectations
were exceeded with open prostatectomy
when we compared them to robotic
prostatectomy early on I think I didn't
do a good job to explain patients what
the outcomes would be of these patients
we were still on our learning curve but
I think much has changed since his
publication that I was part of at Duke
University we now know from the
literature that robotic assistance does
offer superior outcomes when we compare
them to laparoscopic radical
prostatectomy there is less pain smaller
incisions less scarring and a faster
recovery and indeed if we start to look
at some of the the literature Andy
Vickers in 2012 looked at this in a
publication in neurology and stated you
know the great meaningless questions in
urology which is better open
laparoscopic or robotic radical
prostatectomy and it should be obvious
what is better open pure or laparoscopic
or robotic is really meaningless outside
the context of the learning curve as you
can see Matt cooperberg in San Francisco
published an article in the Journal of
Clinical Oncology the outcomes of
radical prostatectomy is it the singer
the song or both and indeed the robot
will not transform a bad surgeon into a
good one but it helps high volume
surgeons to further improve their
outcomes and ultimately shorten the
learning curve for surgeons in training
but let's look at some of the details
between robotic prostatectomy and
laparoscopic prostatectomy and then we
will go on and discuss open
prostatectomy indeed when you look at a
publication in 2011 in the Journal of
Sexual Medicine a very good peer
reviewed journal robotic surgery in the
blue line indeed shows better earlier
return to countenance ninety-four
percent versus eighty-three percent
compared to those that underwent a
laparoscopic procedure when you look at
potency you can see that potency
recovery is significantly better when
you see compare it to the laparoscopic
approach at 12 months seventy-seven
percent recovery of the ability to have
intercourse verses thirty two percent
across the board again in the European
urology publication by Puerto pawa
looking at continents rates and patients
robotic prostatectomy you can see at
three months was eighty percent at six
months eighty-eight percent and in 12
months ninety-five percent compared to
the laparoscopic approach where 12
months was eighty-three percent when you
look at potency across the board a
similar pattern emerges this publication
again from the same author suggests that
an eighty percent potency rate can be
achieved in 12 months compared to a
fifty-four percent with the laparoscopic
approach so indeed we see these numbers
are extremely encouraging for the
robotic approach but let's look at the
open approach as dr. lepore has stated
that there you know are many advantages
with the open approach but what are the
real advantages and first I'd like to
focus on perioperative outcomes indeed
in this article published in JAMA men
undergoing minimally invasive radical
prostatectomy compared to those that
underwent robotic can expect the shorter
length of stay fewer respiratory or
surgical complications and strictures
and post-operative use of additional
cancer therapies will be achieved with
the robotic approach and European
urology in 2012 Jim who states the men
undergoing a minimally invasive approach
experience fewer perioperative and late
complications although minimally
invasive complications decreased over
the study period open prostatectomy
complications increased
envy these were associated with higher
mortality here you can see as a
meta-analysis looking at perioperative
outcomes those to the right of the
central line are in favor of a robotic
approach versus those to the left are in
favor of an open approach and across the
board in this publication you can see
that perioperative outcomes and
complications based on a mounted
analysis suggests that the robotic
approach is superior and indeed when you
look at this robotic prostatectomy can
routinely performed with a small risk of
complications and this cumulative
analysis demonstrates that blood loss
and transfusion rates were significantly
lower with the robotic approach when
compared to the open approach if you
look at positive surgical margins and
perioperative complication rates you can
see the positive surgical margins for
organ confined disease were similar
between two approaches when you saw a
disease pt3 disease you see it's
favoring open surgery but when we look
at intra-operative with perioperative
complications the robotic approach is
indeed favored across the board so
indeed in this meta-analysis improved
perioperative morbidity profiles we're
seeing with the robot compared to the
laparoscopic as well as the open
approach here you can see is results
from a nationwide inpatient sample base
and indeed when you look at
perioperative and post-operative
complications significantly less with
the robotic approach when compared to
the open approach and indeed the length
of stay is much shorter with the robotic
approach across the board dr. lepore who
is a very skilled open surgeon has very
low hospitals of hospitalization rates
but in the general public not everyone
does have the skill set that dr. laporte
has the robotic approach tends to be
much better with length of stay come
pair to the open approach here are
articles and summaries taken from the
AUA updates comparing open prostatectomy
looking at perioperative operative x
blood loss across the board and
complication rates and indeed when you
compare this with the robotic series the
numbers with regards the perioperative
copper ative complications is much lower
with the robotic approach let's look at
positive surgical margins and compare
this with the open approach dr. lepore
when he does his surgery indeed we saw
his cut his positive margin rate went
from nineteen point eight percent down
to about nine percent one of the early
arguments that many open prostatectomy
surgeon said is that by feeling the
tumor you could get a better margin in
these individuals and indeed when you
look at this is palpating the prostate
reliable and allowing us to appreciate
margins the answer is no the majority of
these tumors that we find it surgery are
not palpable but indeed the newer robots
now have haptic feedback interesting
this doesn't really change outcomes that
we've seen in these individuals if
tactile sensation was so important why
are the margins lower with robotics and
indeed one thing that we have learned
with robotic surgery is that we're able
to grade the type of nerve spare that we
can do you can see that this is an
article that was published in European
urology in 2012 and one can grade the
type of nerve spare that was done here
you see his work from the Patels lab
down in florida you can see in diagram a
a nice nerve spear is done you can see
this is considered a 5 out of a score of
54 complete nurse bear being done on a
prostatectomy specimen and you compare
that with slide e where you have extra
prosthetic extension going into the
nerve this is a grade 1
type of nerve spared so the pathologist
is able to grade the type of work that
we do robotic Lee and indeed we can try
to predict what some of our functional
outcomes may be here you can see with mr
technology here is a patient that's
having extra prosthetic extension there
is a suggestion that the disease extends
outside the margin here and indeed with
this we can now do what we call a
partial nerve spare so we can look at
this here you can see our Web Clips
being placed down and indeed the
visualization and trying to peel this
off where this extra prosthetic
extension exists we can swing things a
little bit wider to try to allow for a
better oncological result and indeed you
can see as we start to peel this tissue
away we can find what we're doing very
very nicely and the visualization I
think one head can appreciate that you
can start to see this tissue and peel
this away very nicely so indeed when we
start to look at oncological outcomes
with robotic surgery here you can see as
a meta-analysis published in 2012 and
european neurology clearly favoring to
the right robotic prostatectomy with
oncological outcomes compared to open
prostatectomy and indeed when you look
at this you can see that the numbers of
these patients across the board you know
may favor slightly the robotic approach
but clearly there are patients that will
benefit with positive surgical margins
with the open approach so contrary to
what dr. lepore has told you I believe
that the positive surgical margin rates
may be slightly lower or at least equal
with open prostatectomy across the board
and indeed here's a multi-institutional
study looking at over 22,000 patients
that underwent an open laparoscopic and
robotic approach you can see that the
positive
margin with the robot was thirteen
percent where the open prostatectomy was
twenty-two percent across the board and
indeed this is statistically significant
so here positive surgeon margin rates
might be lower with a minimally invasive
approach compared to an open radical
approach let's look at our lymph node
dissection and indeed this is an
important part of our operation when we
see patients that have higher grade
tumors we sample lymph nodes and can we
do as good a sampling as what we've seen
with the open surgeons this is a single
group series looking that was published
in 2012 looking at the impact of a
traditional node dissection versus an
extended node dissection both an
intermediate and high risk groups across
the board and indeed intermediate and
high risk patients I think an extended
lymph node dissection appears to be
better for these patients in this risk
group here's an article that pump that
was published with regards to bladder
cancer by raaz proof lead down at the
University of North Carolina and indeed
when you look at the robotic sampling 19
lymph nodes compared to an open 18 lymph
nodes lift load count can be very very
comparable across the board and indeed
when you start to look at the
complications with lymph nodes you can
see that not only extended but limited
as well as standard lymph node by
sections can't be done and indeed across
the board the note counts can be quite
high and quite good pelvic lymph node
dissection during robotic surgery can be
done effectively and safely the number
of nodes removed the likelihood of node
positivity and the complication rates
were very similar to our open
counterpart surgeons we now have new
technology that exists we can use pet CT
choline studies to try to identify where
lymph nodes will be positive and indeed
do a
don't die section that will encompass
these lymph nodes that have a high
suggestion of cancer here you can see is
an extended lymph node dissection I
apologize it's being run a little faster
because it's quite long but here you can
see this sampling that's taking place
the vessels can be peeled off the tissue
on the vessels can be peeled off quite
nicely clips can be applied for the
lymphatic channels and we can do a large
sampling of lymph nodes and be very safe
and efficacious to do this nodal
dissection quite nicely the wet clips
are being placed on these lymphatic
channels and indeed you can see the
bundle that's removed again on the
opposite side going in sampling these
lymph nodes clipping these clips with
clips to stop the lymphatic channels
decrease the risk of lymphocytes but
indeed you can see that the
visualization and teasing this tissue
off these vessels can be achieved very
safely and effectively with the robotic
approach let's look at oncological
outcomes dr. lepore went to great
lengths to look at oncological outcomes
comparing robotic surgeons with their
counterparts with open surgeons and
indeed this is a paper that was
published by Manny Menon from Detroit in
2010 looking at analysis of over 1,300
patients and you can see the chance of
biochemical recurrence following radical
retropubic robotic prosperous robotic
prostatectomy you can see the five-year
follow-up of these patients patients
with low d'amico scores do much much
better compared to those with
intermediate or high grade scores indeed
the robot does offer an advantage in
these individuals again another
publication in 2012 a single European
Center looking at five-year follow-up
again across the board we see a very
similar pattern to what dr. Menon
reported across the board with five
seven and nine year follow-up in these
patients across the board so biochemical
free recurrence rates after robotic
prostatectomy appeared to be consistent
with some of the large open series that
dr. laporte talked about if we look at a
case mix of early oncological outcomes
of open and robotic surgeons you can see
that these lines are almost superimposed
when you start to follow these patients
two three and four years out with indeed
these patients will benefit with a
robotic approach and there's no evidence
to suggest that the robotic approach
results are were psychological outcomes
even in patients with higher risk cancer
what about functional outcomes we talk
about potency and functional outcomes
and indeed this is extremely important
when we start to think about how we do
our nerve spare operation and indeed
this as you can see is the beginning
parts of a nerve spare operation where
we can dissect off the the neuro
vascular bundle alongside the prostate
and free up the neuro vascular bundle
for potency here you can see is the
typical release that's been described by
many different robotic surgeons as we
start to peel this out from the medial
aspect there is a prosthetic vessel if
you will if you want to dissect off out
laterally push that vessel out laterally
and that will allow you to be right on
the prostate capsule itself to do a nice
nerve spare operation we don't use any
electric artery we don't use heat most
of the injury for potency is usually a
traction type of an injury that appears
to be self-limited and hopefully will
return in some patients it doesn't
return in all patients but you can see
that the neuro vascular bundle can be
swept off the prostate here is a very
interesting case from my good friend
the patel down at a celebration hospital
here you can see it's an apical
dissection again remember that the
positive margin rates are going to be
highest at the apex when here you can
see our pudendal accessory pudendal
vessels that have been preserved here
you can see is the apical dissection you
can see this has been dissected off
beautifully again preserving these
pudendal arteries that indeed appear to
help with potency but you can see the
pudendal arteries extending accessory
vessels along side the side of the
prostate and here the prostate has been
dissected off in its entirety if we look
at a retrospective comparison of
retropubic and robotic prostatectomy at
one institution this is from dr. Tiwari
that was published in 2003 we can see
that with the robotic approach as well
as the open approach that's illustrated
in green the comparison of potency of
continents excuse me in this in these
individuals was 44 days with the robotic
approach where you can see the same
group of patients was 160 days in these
open patients if we look at current
outcomes of these individuals and again
looking at continents you can see across
the board this is dr. patel's work
looking at what the overall countenance
is at six months tends to be about
eighty four percent and a 12 months you
can see ranges anywhere from 90 to
ninety-seven percent again more comments
data looking at individuals and
continence rates at three 6 12 and 18
months you can see across the board
these numbers are about fifty six
percent and fifty-seven percent at 12
months eighty and eighty eighty eight
percent at 18 months this is a series
that was published in 2009 if we then
look at continents rates across the
board in some of the more recent series
pairing it to open prostatectomy you can
see that in some series they were
comparable but there is a shite a slight
shift towards the robotic approach with
return to countenance I think that we
can say comfortably that the return to
countenance timing appears to be very
comparable across the board in these
individuals with an odds ratio of 1.53
so for the first time here is
statistical evidence suggesting robotic
prostatectomy being better than open and
laparoscopic prostatectomy with regards
to countenance recovery again if we look
at potency rates and here you can see is
a number of series of individuals across
the board and meta-analysis if you will
looking at potency rates across the
board using validated questionnaires or
interviews in these individuals much
what we saw with continents we now start
to see what potency and indeed you can
see there's one series here that
suggests better outcomes with an open
prostatectomy but clearly the majority
of these series and if you look at the
odds ratio again 2.94 times greater
chance of return to potency of 12 months
with the robotic approach so again for
the first time we see a significant
advantage in favoring robotic
prostatectomy across the board the
question is what is the promise of
trying to do a randomized control trial
for surgical interventions well I think
randomization will be refused by
patients it will lead to poor accrual
which will under power these studies and
blinding the surgeons you know is going
to be impractical and probably not able
to be done in these individuals across
the board and indeed there is difficulty
in controlling for the skill set and
experience between surgeons and centers
across the board here you can see is a
publication that was published in 2014 a
report of the progress report each
person has been in
oft or performed greater than a thousand
prostatectomy those were the criteria of
the surgeons various components of the
operation were performed by trainee
surgeons under close observation and
indeed when we start there's much
promise as many of you know in the
Olympics when Oscar pretorius was a
runner for South Africa indeed when you
start to see early on there's a lot of
promise in individuals but the question
is is will this promise stick up and
indeed it's going to be very interesting
when this open trial of open and robotic
prostatectomy is completed dr. lepore
alluded to different costs associated
with robotic prostatectomy and indeed if
you look at open prostatectomy compared
to the robotic approach there's no
question that it costs more the surgical
costs are fixed and they're much much
higher but this is an interesting
article that was written by dr. das
gupta a good friend of mine it appeared
in the british journal in 2012 most of
the existing studies have failed to
mention additional costs associated with
treatments of perioperative
complications days out of work and long
term complications such as erectile
dysfunction and incontinence and if
robotic surgery were to yield a better
quality of life this can have an impact
in the quality of life and it may be of
little direct importance to the hospital
but it's highly relevant to society as a
whole indeed I think we're starting to
see different robotic systems being
developed here you can see is a German
robotic system that's being developed in
Canada the Titan robotic system indeed
robotic system development is clearly a
hot topic google maps and is teaming
with johnson & johnson to develop a
robot and there are other robots in
Japan and China that are coming down the
pike which will indeed lower the cost
and increase competition for these
robotic
systems there is a steep learning curve
associated with robotic surgery and I
can tell you my first robotic
prostatectomy took eight and a half
hours my average time now of doing a
robotic prostatectomy after over 1,700
prostatectomies is about an hour and a
half so indeed you get better at doing
robotic surgery and indeed this is a
article that was published by Andy
Vickers looking at surgical margin rates
after open and radical and robotic
prostatectomy that learning curve seems
to be you know around 500 to really get
quite good at this operation ways that
we can surpass the learning curve are
with simulators and virtual Mentors we
now have dual consoles and we can in do
remote presence proctoring for
individuals to try to get them up to
speed dr. lepore showed this slide and
indeed there has been bad marketing you
know you know we need to be more
truthful when we talk about robotic
surgery because the technology does
offer a nice advantage for some
individuals here you can see an article
that was published can good marketing
carry a bad product and this is actually
what dr. lepore has suggested but I
think marketing can generate short-term
success but the quality is the primary
long-term success driver and indeed what
we're seeing with robotic surgery is
we're seeing quality outcomes being
obtained across the board so in
conclusion dr. lepore is a very skilled
surgeon but dr. lepore is a little
behind the curve robotics has been
widely adopted since its first come in
and it's currently the most common
surgical approach for prostatectomy in
the United States and indeed will become
the most common approach across the
world in the near future there is no
question that there are better outcomes
and we've seen this with level one
evidence looking at compared to
Shoppach prostatectomy we when we start
to do a systemic review of the evidence
we can see better outcomes and
functional outcomes and equivalent
cancer control when we compare it to the
open approach but their lack of
randomized control trials as dr. lepore
had said in the literature but problem
is we need to get over it we need to use
this technology we need to use it as
best we can and advance it as Charles
Darwin said it's not the strongest of
the species that survive nor the most
intelligent that survives it's the ones
that are most adaptable to change dr.
lepore it's time to change I'd like to
thank dr. Coello and dr. Patel for
helping me with this presentation thank
you very much wow thank you thank you
vote for such an informative
presentation lots of good information
there apologies we do not have time for
any question and answers I do want to
thank both our physicians who took their
time to spend with us today dr. Hobart
before and dr. David alfama wonderful
information brought to us today we also
want to thank our presenters lab routes
comm a leading scientific social
networking site for making this
presentation possible please visit us at
wwe.com today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing on our
website to march of 2016 we'll let you
know when it's been put up there for
viewing and we encourage you to forward
that any right to any colleagues you may
have that could not make today's live
broadcast thank you again for joining us
see you next time